[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: OK.
Well, welcome back to
another problem session.
It's great to see everybody's
smiling faces again.
Right, so today, we're
going to continue
our discussion of
graph theory problems,
this time focusing on,
well, a little bit of this,
a little bit of that, some
shortest past problems,
all pairs shortest path,
and then modification
of the Dijkstra's algorithm
to finish us off for the day.
So as always, we'll go through
our problem session problems
in order, for no reason
other than that's
the way they were
presented to me,
and I think roughly
isomorphic to how
most of the homeworks
in this class go anyway.
But in any event,
let's get started here.
So in problem session
problem 7-1 here,
as always, our first
problem is sort of a warm-up
to make sure that we understand
all these sort of definitions,
techniques that we use in 6.006.
Today, we're going to go
over Dijkstra's algorithm.
So if y'all recall, Dijkstra's
algorithm is a technique
for computing shortest path from
a single source to your rest
of your graph.
There's about a
million different ways
to explain, understand
Dijkstra's algorithm.
So I'll undoubtedly revert
upon the one that I remember,
which is probably not
the one that Jason just
covered in lecture.
But we'll make it work.
And of course, if there
are any questions,
we'll address those
along the way.
I'm going to switch to
a piece of chalk that
isn't an eight of an
inch and get started.
Right, so in problem 1A
our homework here, we
were asked to run Dijkstra's
algorithm from vertex s here.
By the way, just sort of
a standard terminology
in graph theory that I think
we'll see a lot in the homework
is we typically use s for
the sort of starting point
of a path, or sometimes
the source if we're
talking about network flows.
But I don't think we
do those in this class.
And then t is usually
the destination.
Why t, you might ask?
Because it's the letter after s.
Right, so our first
task here is to compute
the single-source shortest
path from s to everything
else in our graph.
Initially, this looks painful.
But it's not.
So you're going to forgive me.
I'm going to write a sort of
shorthand version of Dijkstra's
algorithm, because I'm
talking to you as I solve
this problem, which
of course would
be much more annoying for
you guys to do on paper.
But that's life in the city.
So there.
That's my-- in the
words of Britney Spears,
it's my prerogative
as your instructor.
OK, so in Dijkstra's
algorithm, what do we do?
We initially label
all of our vertices
as having distance infinity
to the source, or--
and we insert them into
our priority queue,
except for one vertex, which
of course is our source vertex.
And he or she has distance 0
for an obvious reason, which
is that if my path
starts at the source,
it has distance 0 to the source.
So as our shorthand--
what was that?
Do I want to use red?
Yes, of course I do.
But see, it's this
fat chalk, man.
OK.
0.
I can make this work.
OK.
So our convention
for today is going
to be if a vertex does
not have a label on it,
it is distance infinity.
So what does Dijkstra's
algorithm do?
Dijkstra's algorithm
grabs the closest vertex
that I haven't yet
processed, and closest
in terms of the
distance value that I've
stored at that vertex, and then
updates all of its neighbors
using sort of a triangle
inequality style construction.
So let's see what
that looks like.
So so far, everything is
distance infinity away,
except for one vertex, which is
vertex s, which is distance 0.
So obviously, that should
be our first iteration
of Dijkstra's algorithm.
And now what vertex
S is going to do
is look at all of s's
neighbors and update them
using the triangle inequality.
And if they're closer by
having a path through s
to the neighbor, then
I update the distance.
And if it's not, then I don't.
In this case,
everything is infinity.
So it's pretty clear that I
should route my path through s,
because any distance
less than infinity
is smaller than infinity.
So in particular, notice that
there's an edge of length
8 from s to a.
So now, rather than being
distance infinity away,
I can see that vertex
a is really distance 8.
Oh, this chalk gives me shivers.
Similarly here, there's
an edge of length 7.
And I believe that's all
of the edges out of s.
So we're good.
And now the kind of
nice thing about the way
Dijkstra's algorithm
works, which
I guess was a little bit
implicit in the construction we
saw yesterday, but
that's OK, is that once
I visit a vertex, I
never touch it again.
It gets frozen in time--
in distance, I suppose.
But in any event,
what that means
is I'm going to put a little
box around it, meaning I'm
done with this guy.
He is no longer in my queue.
OK.
Hopefully our pictorial
system makes some sense here.
Again, on your homework
problem, you actually
have to write this stuff out.
And I'm sorry.
That sucks.
But I don't have to, because
I'm talking to you all today.
OK, so remember
Dijkstra's algorithm.
We're going to look at
our list of vertices
we haven't seen yet.
So it's everything except for
S. Find the one that's closest.
And process that one next.
So in this case,
that's the 7 here.
OK, so let's take a look.
What are the neighbors of 7?
Well, I've got s.
And that's-- oh, and d here.
OK.
So first of all, let's
take a look at s.
Obviously, if I have
a path that goes
through c, back through
this vertical edge to s,
that path has length 8, right?
7 plus 1.
8 is bigger than 0.
So I do not update s.
But we actually
already knew that,
because s was frozen here.
So I didn't even have
to look at that edge.
I could have removed
it if I wanted to.
OK.
But there's another
edge coming out
of c, which is pointing
toward d, that has length 4.
7 plus 4 is, wait for it, 11.
And that's less than infinity.
So I update d's distance to 11.
And I don't think I've
managed to make a mistake yet.
OK, so now, we've looked
at all the edges out of c.
And c is frozen.
And we move on.
OK, next, let's see.
On the other vertices, we
have infinity, 8, and 11.
So the smallest of those
three numbers is 8.
And we're going to update
all the neighbors of the 8,
which, thankfully, although
this graph looks big,
they had some mercy on your
section instructor today.
And really, there
aren't that many edges.
So this isn't too
hard to process.
But here's the thing.
There's an edge of length
0 from a to d here.
I can get to the a in 8 units.
So I can also get to the d in 8
units by traversing that edge.
8 is less than 11.
That's good news.
Do I want to erase
it or scratch it out?
What's going to be better?
I'll scratch it out,
just to be messy.
OK.
So now, d has a distance
8 from vertex s.
And I believe that's
all the edges out of a.
So a is set.
OK.
This fun or what?
So now we look at all
the edges out of--
oh, sorry.
We step back, and we look
at all of our vertices.
We find the closest one.
That's d.
And now we've got to update
all of d's neighbors.
So thankfully, all
the remaining vertices
have distance infinity.
So what do we know?
There's an edge
of length 1 here.
So we get a 9.
There's an edge of length 2.
So I get a 10.
And I believe those are all
the outgoing edges from d.
And now d's set.
I'm going to start
moving faster,
because this is hella boring.
OK.
Now the next closest
edge is the 9.
Notice that the 9 only--
or rather, b, I suppose,
is the vertex, which is
currently at distance 9.
It only has one neighbor that
hasn't yet been processed,
which is e.
So we know that that's 9,
10, 11, 12 distance away.
I'm going to check
my scrap paper
and make sure I haven't
made any mistakes yet.
7, 8.
Cool.
OK.
So now our next
closest vertex is
vertex h, which is distance 10.
And aha!
If I traverse the edge
upward from h to e,
I can get a path of length 11.
And 11, according to
most mathematicians,
is less than 12.
And hence, we should
update the value here.
In addition to that, there is
an edge of length 2 out of h,
pointing into g.
10 plus 2 is 12.
And I believe that's it.
Getting there.
OK, so the next
closest vertex is e.
e has no outgoing edges.
So e is all set.
After that, we've got g.
g has an outgoing edge
of length 1 into d.
12 plus 1 is 13, which
is larger than 8.
So we don't update.
And similarly, 12 plus
0 is bigger than 7.
So we don't update.
But again, the edges
that point into vertices
that we've already
processed, we really
don't have to even
consider, just by the way
that Dijkstra's algorithm works.
Notice that if there were
a negative weight edge,
we're going to come back
to, then that assumption
would be problematic.
So the takeaway here is that
this guy is frozen in stone.
And now, notice that our
queue is actually empty, yeah?
So depending on how we set up
our-- well, it's not empty.
But it only contains one vertex.
And it's at distance infinity.
Infinity plus 0
is still infinity.
So that's this
guy's distance here.
And now our queue is empty.
Sorry.
OK, so I believe I
managed to do that right.
Excellent.
So the problem asked
for two things.
It asked for the single-source
shortest path distance.
It also asked for
the traversal order,
which I forgot to do while
I was doing this problem.
But you could retrace
it pretty easily.
OK, so that's part
A. Then in part B,
they say, change the
weight of the edge from g
to c to minus 6.
So we have g to c.
And now, instead of 0, we're
going to make it minus 6.
And the question is, if I
ran Dijkstra's algorithm,
essentially, what would break?
And I think it's
pretty easy to eyeball.
Remember that g was essentially
the less interesting vertex
that we touched in
our algorithm here.
The only one that
we looked at was f.
And so this outgoing
edge from g actually
wouldn't even be seen
by Dijkstra's algorithm,
thankfully, until we've touched
all these other vertices
in an identical fashion
to our previous traversal.
And then we finally get to g.
And now what's going to happen?
Well, if I had this edge
of length negative 6,
what's 12 minus 6?
That's 6.
And notice that
that's less than 7,
which is the label of vertex c.
But that breaks our
assumption, which
is that as soon as
I visit a vertex,
I never have to touch
it again, right?
Because now I've identified
a path through g,
back to c, that has a similar
distance than the path
that c had when it was
visited in the queue.
So somehow, spiritually, I
should add c back to the queue.
But that's against the rules
in Dijkstra's algorithm.
So for instance, if I did that,
I would have to convince myself
that the runtime doesn't
explode and that this algorithm
terminates, which
could be a problem
if you have a
negative weight cycle.
Thankfully, we have algorithms
for detecting negative weight
cycles.
But that's a different matter.
OK, so I think this is
pretty straightforward.
It's just essentially
asking you to walk
through Dijkstra's algorithm
and make sure you understand
what's going on.
Any questions about that one?
Cool.
I think this is one of the
easier problem sessions.
So maybe we'll finish
early, except I always say
that, and then I talk too much.
Sorry.
Not sorry.
OK.
So, right.
So in problem 7-2, this is
an extension of a problem
that we considered, I believe,
two problem sessions ago.
And it looks
something like this.
I'm going to go
back into my notes.
So remember, in two
problem sessions
ago, we defined the
radius of the graph
for an unweighted graph.
We came up with an algorithm for
computing it and approximating
it, all that good stuff.
Now, in this
problem, we're going
to do basically the same thing.
But now we're on a
weighted graph, yeah?
So in particular, we're
going to define a quantity--
this is problem 2--
called weighted
eccentricity, which
is associated to a vertex
in a weighted graph.
And it looks like this.
So the weighted eccentricity
associated to vertex u
is equal to the max
over all vertices
in my graph of the shortest path
distance from u to that vertex.
Again, hopefully
our audience will
catch if I accidentally swap
the argument to shortest path.
I'm used to thinking
of that as symmetric,
but it's not, because
our graph's directed.
Actually, in this
problem, I don't think
the graph is directed, so--
I forget.
It's directed.
OK, good.
Yeah, then good.
I'll try to be accurate.
[LAUGHS] OK, and
just like the problem
we had two problem sessions
ago, so the eccentricity
that's associated with a vertex
is sort of like the distance
to the farthest-away
thing in my graph.
And now the radius
of my graph tries
to find the most
central vertex, which
is the minimizer of
weighted eccentricity.
And we call that
the weighted radius.
And so the rated--
agh.
Oof, that's a tough one.
The weighted radius
is a measurement,
which is associated
not with a vertex,
but rather with the graph.
And it's equal to the min
over all possible vertices, u,
of the weighted
eccentricity of u.
OK, and so the problem
here is that we're
given a weighted directed graph
with no negative weight cycle.
So it may have negative weights.
But they can't have
a negative cycle.
And the question--
oh, I touched my face.
The question is, what is the--
can I find the
radius of my graph
in time that looks
like order mod v cubed?
Now, if you recall from our
previous problem session,
when we considered computing
the radius of a graph, what did
we do?
Well, we tried to come up
with a clever algorithm.
And then we realized
that that was actually
kind of unnecessary.
It turned out that the
kind of braindead thing,
where you just look
at the definitions
and just make it work,
was actually good enough.
And that actually turns out
to be the case here, right?
This is a good reminder for us
all that before we go crazy--
6.006 is a fun algorithms class.
We get to learn
about cute references
to TV shows and all that.
Before we go crazy
with that, of course,
if there's an obvious algorithm
staring us in the phase
to solve a given
algorithms problem,
we should try that first before
we try something more clever.
And indeed, in this
case, that works.
So what are the sort
of ingredients that we
need to compute the radius?
Well, the radius is the
minimum eccentricity.
So what would be the smartest--
or the simplest thing to do,
rather, would be compute the
eccentricity for every vertex
and take the smallest.
How do I compute the
eccentricity for every vertex?
Well, I have to have the max
distance away from that vertex.
So what would be a
simple thing to do
would be to compute
distances between all
the possible vertices.
And conveniently, in lecture,
in some day or another--
I'm a little confused about the
time ordering of this class,
because of the way
we're filming it--
we uncovered an algorithm
that computes the distance
between every pair of vertices.
And that's called
Johnson's algorithm.
So if we were to do a totally
braindead version of solving
this problem, maybe for
convenience, the first thing
we'd do is compute delta u, v
for every possible u, v pair.
And because our graph doesn't
have a negative weight cycle,
we can do that with
Johnson's algorithm.
So step one is to use Johnson's
algorithm for all pairs,
shortest path.
And I'll refer you guys to
lecture for how to do that.
But the important
thing is the runtime
of this step of our algorithm.
So Johnson's algorithm,
generically speaking,
has ve plus v squared log v--
hopefully I got that right--
runtime.
And what do we know
about our problem?
Well, I believe we're given
that the graph is connected.
And so one thing that
we can do is notice
that e is upper
bounded by v squared--
I guess even if
it's not connected.
I'm sorry.
That was a dumb thing to say.
Just generically speaking,
our graph is simple.
So we know that e, at most,
is, I guess, 2v squared,
which means that this term
is upper bounded by v cubed,
right?
So we have v cubed
plus order v squared
log v. And so at the end of
the day, the first term wins.
And we have that
this is v cubed time.
Notice that we're given
that budget in the statement
of our problem.
So this is perfectly fine.
In other words, this is a
long-winded way of saying,
it's kosher to compute
all pairs shortest
paths in the constraints
of our problem here.
So that's convenient,
because now, in step two,
well, maybe now we just keep--
we do the Toucan
Sam approach again.
We follow our noses.
And well, now that we have
our pairwise distances,
we can now compute the
eccentricity for every vertex,
for all u, just directly.
Of course, in your homework,
you should write out
what that means.
But here, directly just
means that for every u,
I loop over every v, and I
take whatever value is biggest.
So notice that I have two
loops, 1 over u, 1 over
v. So this is order
mod v squared time.
So already, the first
term is dominating here.
So that's a good thing, I guess.
And then finally, we
have to take the smallest
eccentricity of
any u, which, this
requires one more for loop.
So this time, I for
loop over this array.
And I just take the
smallest value, right?
So this is just one for loop.
So that takes order v time.
And then we're done, right?
So that's our technique
for computing the radius.
And notice that all I did
was translate the definition
into an algorithm.
I didn't do anything smart
in this problem at all.
And then we should really
quickly double check
our runtime.
So step one takes v cubed time.
Step two takes v squared times.
Step three takes v time.
So I add them all together.
And of course, the v cubed wins.
And that is what was given
in our problem as our budget.
OK, so I think the first
two problems in this problem
session are fairly
straightforward.
Are there any questions so far?
I'm talking fast.
Cool.
All right, so now we're going
to move on to problem 3,
involving Atniss Keverdeen,
who is probably playing the--
what, the Gunger Hames?
Unger Games.
I was close.
Sorry, Under-- ah, whatever.
You get the point.
Yeah, so before I
get carried away
trying to read
Jason's jokes here,
what's going on in this problem?
So this is problem 3.
There's an underground
sewer network.
I suppose he also could have
written this problem about MIT,
right?
There's all kinds of crazy
underground tunnels here.
I remember when I was looking
at MIT as a potential undergrad,
they had us like schlepping
around the tunnels.
I thought they were very dirty,
and I didn't get the point.
So I went to Stanford.
But in any event, right.
So what I'm given is a map.
And this thing has n
bidirectional pipes.
I'm not going to write it
down, but the problem tells you
that they're all connected.
They make-- like, you
can get from your source
to your target moving
through the pipes.
And right, and they're
connected at junctions.
But at every junction,
there is less than
or equal to four things
that come together.
So just like in our
last session, every time
you see a phrase like
that, it's like screaming
there's a degree bound
hiding inside of your graph.
And moreover, every junction
is reachable from every other
junction, I believe.
OK.
In addition to this, we're
given a positive integer
length for each pipe.
So it's starting to smell
like a shortest path problem.
But is it?
That's our question.
But just to make things
a little bit worse,
Atniss Keverdeen here is trying
to escape through the pipes.
And she doesn't
want to be detected.
And in particular, there exist
junctions with motion sensors.
And apparently, Atniss's
intel is pretty good here.
And she knows which of the
junctions in her pipe network
actually have motion
sensors that can
detect people moving around.
OK.
Now, what this problem is
asking her to do is to say,
maybe-- apparently she knows
where the motion sensors are.
But maybe she doesn't
know if they're like--
what kind of brand they are.
Is it a Microsoft sensor, or
an Apple sensor, or something?
And of course, the sensors
have different ranges.
So Atniss Keverdeen
here, she wants
to be as conservative
as possible
when she traverses
this pipe network.
In particular, what
we're looking for,
what she wants is in
n log n time here,
find the path that maximizes
the distance to the sensors.
So hopefully this
problem makes sense.
So you've got some grid graph.
Well, not necessarily
a grid graph,
but a bunch of vertices
of valence 4, maybe
something like that.
It makes sense.
She's living in
a city somewhere.
And she has some source
that she's starting at,
some destination
she wants to go.
And then a few of
these vertices are
marked as having
motion sensors at them.
And rather than giving
you a radius or something
like that, instead,
what we're saying
is that she wants to go from
the source to the target.
She's willing to
walk a long distance.
The length of the
path doesn't matter.
What matters is that she
never wants to get closer
to any motion sensor--
maybe there's a
second one like here--
than she has to, OK?
So in this case, I guess
if I were to eyeball it,
it looks like you can't do
better than one edge, right?
So she would go like that.
And of course, in
an extreme scenario,
it might be the
case that there's
a sensor in every junction,
in which case she's hosed.
But we'd like to let
her know that before she
embarks upon her journey here.
OK, so does our problem
make enough sense?
Excellent.
OK.
So, right.
So unfortunately for
us, this isn't-- again,
it doesn't look like a
shortest path problem.
And the reason is
because it's not.
But rather, it's sort
of a readability problem
in disguise.
And let's think about
what I mean here.
So, right.
So there's an
obvious graph here--
we'll call it G out of
a lack of creativity--
where what I'm going to do is
give a vertex per junction.
And I'll have an undirected
edge for each pipe
whose weight is the length.
OK.
By the way, I think the length--
I didn't even mention it
in the problem description.
But I believe she wants
to find the shortest
path that maximizes the radius.
So like, if there are multiple
different paths that she could
take that both have the same
radius from the sensors,
then she'd like to be
lazy and not walk too far.
So that's where this is
going to come into play.
But that's sort of
a secondary concern,
I would imagine, on
Atniss's behalf here.
OK.
And moreover, I'm not
going to even attempt
to remember the details
of this problem.
But rather, there's
a source, which
I'm sure has some cute Hunger
Games name attached to it,
and some other target.
And these are just two nodes
in the network of pipes.
And she wants a
path from s to t.
OK.
So first of all, let's
just count and make sure
that we know.
So how many vertices are there?
Well, the problem actually
gives a name to that.
There's order n vertices,
because that's just
the number of junctions, which
is what we define to be n.
I guess I forgot to
write that there.
And because we have a degree
bound, our favorite argument
in this class, we know that
there's order n edges as well.
So that's good news.
Why can't I use
this graph directly?
Like, let's say that I computed
the shortest path from s to t.
Notice that that completely
ignores the point
of the problem, right?
The point of the
problem is that Atniss
wants to avoid these starred
vertices on our graph up here.
But the shortest
path may not do that.
In other words, you
may have to walk
like a really
indirect path to avoid
being detected by the sensors.
That's a problem.
So we need to be a little
more clever than that.
We do have to think
on this problem a bit,
but not too much.
And so here's the basic trick.
Like, let's say
that-- let's have
a slightly different
problem first, which
is, let's say that I give you
a radius k, and I want to know,
does there exist a
path that can get me
from s to t without coming
more than distance k away
from the sensors?
Notice that once I--
if I have a tool that
can answer that like
yes or no problem,
I could come up with
an algorithm that
finds my number of sensors by
looping over k or something.
it may not be fast enough.
But I could do that.
OK, so that problem is actually
not terribly difficult,
because essentially, what
I could do conceptually
is just remove the vertices that
are too close to the sensors
and then solve a
reachability problem.
Like, can I get from s to t
without getting distance k away
from any one of the sensors?
Well, what do I do?
I just remove any
vertex that's distance k
away from the sensors.
And then I compute reachability.
So conceptually, I think
this isn't a huge leap,
intuitively speaking.
But there's a lot of
details to fill in, yeah?
So unraveling just
a little bit more,
we might define a graph Gk.
And Gk is going to be
the subgraph of vertices
whose distance--
distance bigger than k
to any sensor, right?
And somehow, reachability
in this thing
can answer, yes or
no, can I get from s
to t without coming
distance k to a sensor?
By the way, do we know this
term, subgraph, in this class?
Essentially, it's pretty clear
what it is just from the word,
right?
Like, essentially,
I'm just going
to remove vertices inside of
our larger graph and any edges
that touch those vertices.
And obviously, if my original
graph had order n size,
then the subgraph
has big O of n size.
You might have less.
But certainly, it's
an upper bound.
OK, so we unravel
a little bit more.
And somehow, this seems
like a convenient structure.
But I haven't told
you how to compute it.
And in particular, the
sort of annoying thing
is this piece, right?
I need to be able
to figure out if I'm
distance k from any sensor.
Or more generically
speaking, it might
be kind of handy to compute
distance from every--
from the set of sensors
to every other vertex
in my graph, every other
junction in my pipe network,
OK?
Well, we already covered a
trick in our problem sessions
that's going to help
us do that, right?
Because, OK, what would
be a very simple algorithm
for doing that?
It would be to loop
over every sensor,
call Dijkstra's
algorithm for each one.
So that gives me the
distance to sensor number 1,
and the distance
the sensor number 2,
distance to sensor number 3.
And then I take the
min over all those.
And that function gives me
the distance to any sensor.
That's going to
be problem, right?
Because Dijkstra's algorithm
runs in n log n time.
But now I've incurred
another factor,
because I have to loop
over all the sensors.
And we didn't give you a
bound on how many there are.
So more generically,
this is actually
a problem that shows up all the
time in my everyday life, which
is that we don't just
want compute shortest path
to a single point.
Sometimes we want shortest
path to a bunch of stuff.
Like, in other
words, I don't care
which sensor is close to me.
I don't want to get close
to any sensor, yeah?
This shows up in
geometry all the time.
Like, maybe I want
to know the closest--
like, I want to find the
closest point on the highway.
So the highway is
driving past my house.
So the highway is a whole bunch
of points on some network.
And I just want to get on the
highway and start driving.
I don't care about
the closest path
to every single
point on the highway.
I just want whatever is
closest to me, right?
So this is a pretty practical
thing to think about.
So how do we solve that?
So let's say this
is our pipe network.
I feel like I draw
this network a lot.
Maybe I'll spice it
up with an extra edge.
And maybe, for board
drawing purposes,
these two vertices have sensors.
So I'm trying to find the
shortest path distance
to either one of
these two vertices
from every other vertex on
the graph, or vice versa.
It doesn't matter.
It's undirected.
And I don't want to loop
over all these sensors.
That's the basic headache here.
So one thing that I can do--
this is kind of a sneaky trick.
And it's exactly the same trick
that we've applied a few times
in the problem sessions here--
is to add a new vertex
that's kind of like a source
and make that vertex distance
0 to every one of my sensors.
And now what I'm going to do is
do single source, shortest path
from this new extra
vertex that I added
to all the rest of my graph.
Now, why do I do that?
Well, if you think
about it, well, there's
an edge of length
0 to any sensor.
Topologically, I can think of
it like I glued all the sensors
into one vertex if I wanted.
But that doesn't really matter.
I feel like that would
be a different way
to solve this problem, I guess,
would be to take all the sensor
vertices, glue them
together into one,
and then solve this problem.
But I digress.
Right, so the shortest path
distance from our new source
vertex to all the
other ones is going
to be just the short
path to any sensor,
because notice that any path
coming out of s necessarily
has to pass through
a starred vertex.
OK, so let's write that down.
Basically, what I'm trying
to do here is, in step one
of my algorithm, I want to label
each junction with its distance
to a sensor.
That's the high-level goal here.
And the way that I'm going to
do that is I'm going to make--
oops, in the problem
solution, they called it x.
So I'll be consistent.
I'm going to make a new
vertex, or a new graph,
rather, G prime, which is
equal to my original graph, G,
which is coming from
the pipe network,
with one extra vertex,
which we're going
to call x, which is connected
to every motion sensor
with weight 0.
And now I'm going to
do Dijkstra's starting
at x, which takes n log n
time, because I just gave you
the size of our graph up
here, and gives me essentially
the shortest distance to
any motion sensor from all
the vertices in my graph.
So that's a good thing.
That's sort of like a
convenient piece of information.
When we're solving these
kinds of algorithms problems,
notice that I've done sort
of a similar reasoning
in both of the last two
problems, which you can do.
And actually, it's a
pretty practical way
of thinking about algorithms,
where, like, this problem tells
me, at the end of the day, my
algorithm has to run in n log
n time, right?
Or like, in the
previous problem,
it had run in n cubed time--
I guess v cubed time.
So one thing I can
do is say, what
is all the information
that I can gather out
of my graph in n log n time?
And I might as well
compute it, right?
So for instance, the distance
to the closest sensor,
I just gave you an n log n
algorithm for computing it.
That seems like a useful
piece of information.
So what the heck?
I might as well
compute it in step one
and just have it around.
Obviously, you could
do breadth-first search
on all the computable numbers.
And this might not be
the most efficient way
to solve a problem.
But I think for graphs,
there's only so many things
that we typically
want to compute.
So it's worth kind of
going down your checklist.
Like, similarly, here,
notice that we give you
a budget of v cubed time.
So like, you might as well
compute all pairs shortest
path, because we can
do it in v cubed time.
And why not have that
information around?
It seems useful for
computing radius.
OK, so in any event,
now, in step one,
we now know how close every
junction is to every sensor.
So now I can argue--
I'm numbering these like steps.
But they're not really steps.
These are more just
like thought bubbles.
So thought bubble number
two is going to be,
how do I actually
construct Gk, right?
And notice, I have a nice
piece of information here.
I now know what vertices
are inside of Gk
and which ones aren't, right?
Because I can just loop
over all the vertices.
If the distance is
bigger than k, I keep it.
And if it's not, I don't, yeah?
So that gives me an
algorithm for computing Gk.
So we can construct--
"construct" with a C--
construct Gk from our
original graph, G.
And that's really
easy to do, just
by looping over the
vertices and remove
any whose distance is too big--
or too small, rather.
v. Does that make sense?
Because those are the
ones that are dangerous.
If the radius of my sensor is
k, any vertex with distance
less than or equal to
k, I want to throw away.
And how much time
does this take?
Well, there's just a
loop over the vertices.
I guess I need to account for
the storage of my graph also.
But of course, this
graph takes less space
than G. So overall, this
takes order n time--
Tim-- time and space.
But there's a catch, which
is this is per k, OK?
So every time I want
to make a new Gk, I
incur an expense of order n.
But this is already getting us
pretty close to our problem,
because what can we do?
If I have Gk, I can
say that BFS on Gk
establishes reachability
from s to t,
which is what we care
about, outside of radius k.
And how much time does BFS take?
Linear in the size of the graph.
I only ever ask Jason
one question, which is--
always has the same answer.
Right, so BFS takes time linear
in the size of our graph.
Our graph has size
n, or kind of 2n-ish.
So at the end of the
day, this takes order n.
So if our problem were
written slightly differently,
we would be done, right?
If the problem said, given
a radius k and a graph,
tell me, yes or no,
does there exist
a path that stays outside
of radius k of the sensors?
This is how we would do that.
Hopefully we all agree.
And we can do that
in order n time.
Oh, just kidding.
Order n log n time, because I
had to do Dijkstra's algorithm
first.
Thanks.
OK.
But sadly for us,
we're not quite done,
because we want to find
the largest possible k.
We want to find
the biggest radius
that we can stay
away from the sensors
and still get
successfully from s to t.
So let's say that I want
to find this number.
So this is--
I'm going to define k star--
I've got a moving target to
write on-- is the largest k
where Gk is connected--
oh, that's not quite
right-- from s to t.
This is a weird
way to phrase it.
Really, this should say, where
there exists a path from s
to t in Gk.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, where Gk--
I've just phrased
this in a funny way--
has path from s to t.
There we go.
[LAUGHS] All right.
So our question is,
how do we find that?
Well, here's a dumb algorithm.
I could loop over all k's,
construct Gk, and then,
if my answer is,
yes, it's reachable,
then go to the next k, increment
by 1, and start over, right?
So this is the dumb answer.
When I say dumb,
I mean the answer
that your instructor
wrote down on his notes
and then realized it was
dumb, which is loop over k
until you get to k star, I
guess plus 1, because once
I get there, then I
get a thumbs down.
Obviously, getting
any bigger than that
is only going to make
my graph smaller.
This is kind of filtration,
because each graph is contained
inside of a different one.
Actually, a filtration
would be the other way.
I'll think about it for
later, because this is not
a topological data
analysis class.
But in any event, if I did that,
how much time will it take?
Well, remember-- OK,
so for one thing,
I have n log n from
Dijkstra's algorithm.
I don't get around that.
So I always have to
account for that.
But now, every time I try a
new k, I incur cost n, right?
That's what we argued up here.
And so at the end of
the day, this algorithm
takes order k star
n time like that.
Of course, it's a little
weird to have the answer
to your problem in the runtime.
But k star here, it could be--
we don't have any bound here.
It could be the number
of vertices or anything
like that, yeah?
And so if we have a
budget of n log n time,
this doesn't quite work.
And so the question is, can
we rescue this strategy here?
And the answer,
of course, is yes,
or else I wouldn't be
standing here today.
One way that you might
do that-- so there's
the way that you would do that
as a real algorithms person.
And then there's the way you
could do it by psychologically
diagnosing your instructors.
So let's talk about
both of those.
Let's actually do
the second one first,
because I think that's
the most practical if you
want to get your homework done
quickly, which is as follows.
This problem tells you that you
have an n log n budget of time
in order to run the algorithm.
And so what does that mean?
Well, when we loop over
potential Gk's that we can try,
we have a budget of log n
tries before we're done, yeah?
So we kind of know that any
algorithm that constructs a Gk
and tries it can only
do it log n times.
And to my knowledge, we
only have one algorithm
that runs in log n time in this
class, which is binary search.
And so we might be thinking
very critically about how
we could use that tool.
But more generally
than that, I think
this is actually a strategy
that shows up a lot,
both in algorithms and
actually in numerical analysis
a lot, which is, you have
some like yes or no answer.
And you want to find the
point on the interface
where yes flips to no.
And so one way to do it is to
sort of bound it on two ends
and then keep dividing in half.
And as long as your
relationship is a bunch of yeses
and then a bunch of
nos, you can keep
doing that by binary search.
So let's think
about it this way.
So we have a long
interval of k values.
By the way, obviously,
there's an upper bound here,
which is like the
biggest distance
to any vertex in my graph,
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: The sum
of all distances?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah, like the
sum of all distances or some--
AUDIENCE: That would be a very
large number compared to n.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: But
you can afford a lot.
You could-- if you took
the sum of every edge--
here's a way to do it.
If you took this to be the sum
of every possible edge length--
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't that be
bounded in n polynomially?
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
Polynomially bounded in n?
AUDIENCE: Difference
between u and n.
[INAUDIBLE] very large
numbers in the near space.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: OK.
I'm not sure if
that's quite right.
But that's OK.
In any event, let's
say that we have
an upper bound for k for now.
Then what do we know?
We know that here's
the k star that I want.
And to the left, my
algorithm will return yes.
This algorithm up here,
up here, it'll say no.
So one thing I can do--
one thing I should do
is put k star not right
at the center of my interval
for illustration purposes.
But now I can binary
search, right?
Because I could query here.
And now I'm going to get a no.
And maybe I subdivide at the
midpoint for some reason.
Now I get a yes.
And I can kind of triangulate
in on what I want.
So that's our basic strategy
is binary search here.
But we have to figure out
how to do that exactly.
OK, so first of all--
OK, there is an obvious
upper bound here,
which is just the
biggest distance
from any vertex to any sensor.
Right, so we could probably
come up with a conservative one.
We didn't feel like it.
But conveniently, in
step one, remember
that computing convenient
numbers is always
a convenient thing to do.
Clearly, if Katniss wants to--
sorry, Atniss wants to
go within a radius that's
bigger than the distance
of any vertex, any sensor,
she's in trouble, because that
covers the entire graph, yeah?
So right.
So we actually do have
an upper bound here,
which is the biggest
distance to a sensor.
And now we want a binary search.
But we have to be a little
bit careful how to do it,
because we want to
be logarithmic in n,
which is like the number
of vertices in our graph.
And of course, the way that
I've drawn this interval here,
as Jason points out, I
don't, at least immediately,
have a bound on this
number in terms of n.
Like, it could be
that my edge weights
are like really ginormous.
OK, so right.
So how could we get around that?
Well, essentially, what
we want to be doing
is binary search in an array
that scales like the vertices.
And here's the solution
that I came up with,
which I'm pretty sure is the
same as the one in the answer--
I should really check that
before teaching this thing--
which is to do the
following, which is a.
Remember, again, we have
a budget of n log n.
And so we can do a
constant number of things
that take n log n time.
We just might as well
keep doing it, yeah?
And so another kind of
convenient thing we might do
is sort my vertices by
the distance to x, which,
of course, remember,
is exactly the distance
to their closest sensor.
Why would you do that?
Well, in some sense, as
I move along that array,
that's the sort
of order in which
I'm going to remove
vertices from my graph
and make the radius get
bigger and bigger and bigger.
Does that makes sense?
Because these, the
first couple ones
are the ones right
next to the sensor.
As I move along this array, they
get farther and farther away.
OK, so we're going to say-- and
of course, why can we do that?
Because sorting-- I think
this is one that all computer
science students
everywhere know--
takes n log n time using
whatever your favorite
sorting--
well, that's not true-- whatever
my favorite sorting algorithm
is.
OK, and we're going to take
di to be the distance--
the i-th largest-- actually,
I think in my notes,
I got this one--
the i-th smallest.
I'm diverging from my notes.
So there is a high
likelihood of a sign mistake
that's about to happen.
And now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to binary search on i.
In other words, I'm on the
index into my distance array.
There's a reason to do that.
Is there a reason-- like,
let's say that my distances
are like 1, 2, 5, 7.
So these are the distance
of some vertex to a sensor.
And let's say that I test 3.
And I notice that
3 is admissible.
In other words, she
can get from one vertex
to another, never getting
within a radius of 3.
Should I try a radius of 4?
Well, no, because I'm going
to remove vertices only
when I pass an
element in this array.
So it makes sense to do binary
search not in distant space,
but rather in array index
space, because those
are the sort of
junctures that determine
when I'm going to remove stuff.
So, right.
So remember, how
big is this array?
It's got length n.
So overall, this binary
search takes log n time.
And that's good, because
our whole algorithm now--
what do we do?
We binary search on d.
Or rather, we
binary search on i.
And then we take di and
plug it into our algorithm
up there to construct
our subgraph.
We test yes or no.
And that tells us the
left or the right interval
in our binary search.
And we recurse.
And so overall, this takes
log n time, or rather,
log n steps of binary search.
And of course, each one of these
steps, as I argued up there,
takes order n time.
So overall, our algorithm
takes order n log--
oh no, I made an
accidental theta--
n log n time.
And that was the bound
we wanted to achieve.
As usual, there's
a lot of detritus
that we need to clean up at
the end of our problem here.
One of them is that we
actually want to return a path.
But that's not so bad, right?
So now we've
essentially determined
that we can compute k
star in n log n time.
Well, that's good.
So now, if we actually
want the path,
we can construct our graph one
more time, right at k star.
I suppose we already
have it around
from the end of binary search.
And then use whatever your
favorite reachability algorithm
is to go from s to
t and give Katniss
the path that she wants,
or specifically Dijkstra's
algorithm if you want
the shortest path, which
is courteous, because
she doesn't want to walk
too far if she doesn't have to.
Moreover, let's see.
There are a couple
of boundary cases
that are probably worth
mentioning in your problem.
So for instance, if
k star equals 0--
in other words, I
do my binary search.
I get all the way back to the
first element of my array.
And it's still
saying I can't do it.
What does that mean?
That means that I cannot go
from my source to my target node
without passing through a
vertex that has a sensor at it,
in which case, what do you do?
Well, you can return any
path, or you might as well
return the shortest path
so that she can run.
[LAUGHS] OK.
And that, I believe,
concludes our problem.
Any questions about that one?
Thumbs up, cool.
How are we doing on time?
As usual, I think I'm
going to end early.
We're at precisely the same
time I'm always at at problem 4.
OK, so problem 4, we move
from one fictional universe
to another here.
So now we're playing like
Okepon or something like that.
Sorry.
If I didn't write so
big, I wouldn't have
to waste half of class erasing.
But that's OK.
Right, so cool.
So now we have Ashley Gettem.
And Ashley Gettem is trying
to go from Twinkletown
to Bluebluff.
And these are both two
clearings in the Tanko region.
I'm sure if I played Pokemon,
this would have meaning to me,
or whatever this is.
But in any event, we
have a bunch of maps--
we have a map of a
bunch of clearings.
I'm not liking the
erasing on this board.
So maybe we'll start up here.
OK, so we have n clearings.
And they're connected
by two-way trails.
And thankfully,
there's less than
or equal to 5 trails
connecting in every clearing.
This is like our favorite
detail to add to 6.006 problems
is a degree bound, yeah?
OK.
Now, with every
trail, we associate
a length, which we're going
to call l sub t for trail t.
But in addition to
that, we're going
to have another
piece of information,
which is that it has this set
of critters on it, c sub t.
So now every trail--
our character here is
walking along the path.
And what does she want to do?
Any time that she
walks along a path,
she collects a critter,
or however many critters
are on that path.
In fact, she feels
a very similar way
to how I feel at TJ Maxx, right?
She's walking down
the aisles, and like,
she can't help herself.
She's got to catch every critter
that she goes past on the path.
There's no option here.
She can't leave it behind,
because if she does,
then she'll be sad.
And the reason why our
character might not
be able to pick up
one of the critters
would be if she ran
out of her tools
for picking up these
critters, which are apparently
pocket spheres.
And she has k spheres.
In other words, she
has like a backpack.
And the backpack can hold that
many spheres at a time, OK?
There are a few details here.
One is that every time
she walks down a path,
she collects all the critters.
But then if she walks
down that path again,
she'll collect the
same set of critters.
Apparently they respawn.
They're very prolific,
these critters.
And moreover, there are stores
at some of the clearings.
And at these stores,
she can get rid
of the critters
she currently has,
and drop them off, and pick
up empty spheres instead.
So essentially,
every time she does
that, she empties
her backpack and gets
a new set of material,
where she can
keep picking up the critters.
I have many questions
about this character.
Like, does she just
leave them there?
Does she come back
for them later?
What does she do
with the critters?
There's a lot of questions.
Like, does she have a bigger
bag she can go back around
to the stores and--
but in this fictional
universe, we're
not going to worry about
these problems, OK?
And so, right.
So essentially,
the question here
is that there are two locations.
I don't remember the name--
Trundletown to
Bluebluff that she's
trying to travel in between.
And she gets sad if she
comes across a critter
that she can't collect.
So the question is, can
you find the shortest path
without being sad?
And in like kind of a Dada
twist in this problem,
if no such path exists--
in other words, it's like, so
she has to walk along some long
trail with a bunch of critters--
more than k critters, I guess,
in the worst case--
then sadness is unavoidable,
is what your code is apparently
supposed to return, which
is really defeatist.
I don't know who wrote
this problem set.
OK.
The question is, how
do we solve this?
It looks like a
shortest path problem.
But as with all
problems in 6.006,
there's a slight twist, right?
And in this case, the twist
is that it's the shortest path
without becoming
sad, where sadness
means that you ran out
of spheres to collect
your critters.
Whew.
Now, notice that we're
given a budget, by the way,
of, I believe, nk log nk time.
Is that right?
Like that.
OK.
Notice that this is
a little suspicious.
Somehow it makes us think
that the size of our problem
really is nk, rather
than just n or k.
OK, so how could we do this?
Let's think back to a problem
that we solved yesterday,
under the assumption
that you guys are
binge watching your 6.006
problem sessions here.
And remember, in the
problem yesterday, we
had this dude that was
walking along paths.
And like, every third path,
he had to drink a beer.
I've tried this on
my commute home,
and it doesn't
work terribly well.
But in any event, we have
kind of a similar scenario
here, where there's some number
that we need to keep track of,
right?
In this case, it's
the number of critters
that our character has
remaining that she can pick up.
So she starts with an empty bag.
As she collects them, the
amount of capacity in her bag
decreases until she
gets to a store,
and then it goes back again.
But the good news is that our
runtime bound includes k in it.
So it's actually OK to
make an algorithm that
scales in the number of critters
that she can carry around.
That's kind of atypical, but
an interesting choice here.
So remember, the term
I introduced last time
for this kind of
universe is that it's
kind of like a state machine.
Like, in addition to
walking along the graph,
she needs to know how much
capacity she has for critters.
And so here's a way to do it.
So I think, actually, this
problem isn't too bad,
given that you saw
the problem where
you do every third vertex
in our last problem session.
Somehow it's just like a
same church, different pew
kind of scenario here.
So in this case,
one thing we can do
is we're going to make a graph.
We call him G. He's got vertices
v and edges E, just for fun.
But what we're
going to do is have
k plus 1 vertices
for every clearing.
And the reason is that
what we're going to do
is we're going to
walk along the graph.
And as we traverse
our edges, we're
not only going to keep
track of the costs,
like the distance
that she's walking,
but also the number of
critters that she has remaining
in her bag that she can score.
And the way that
we can do that is
by keeping a bunch of
copies of our graph
and ascending every time that
we collect a new critter.
Does that makes sense?
OK so here's a-- let's just add
a little bit more detail here.
So in particular, I
can define vc comma
i is going to be the vertex per
clearing comma critter space.
And the way that
I can view it is
that this is sort
of representing
that I'm at clearing--
oops, that should be a c.
And I have i pocket
spheres that are empty.
So initially, I'm going
to start at v s comma 0
and go from there, OK?
OK.
I guess it depends
whether you're
decreasing it or increasing it.
AUDIENCE: You have empty
pocket spheres [INAUDIBLE]??
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
So in that case, I
guess it would be k.
We'll see if I manage
to do that consistently
throughout my answer here.
OK, so now I need
to tell you how
to make the edges in our graph.
And so let's do that next.
So in particular, for
all trails from a--
between a and b, with
length l and critters c--
so she picks up c critters.
She traverses distance l.
She gets from a to
b or vice versa.
And our trails are
bidirectional here.
We need to define edges.
And they look like this.
So we sort of have
two different cases.
One is where you have a store.
And one is when you
don't, because that's
going to affect how
your state changes.
So, right.
So the first one would be--
oh, did I get this
whole thing backward?
Oh, don't tell me that.
No, I didn't.
OK, good.
Great.
So first case would be
a does not have a store.
So in this case, she
leaves with the same number
of critters she had
in her bag, minus
whatever critters she
picks up along the way.
So now I'm going to have
an edge of length l.
And I'm going to go from va
comma i to vb comma i minus c.
So the idea is that
I go from a to b.
And in the process,
I lose c critters.
But I have to do this for
all the possible i's that I
could see in my state.
So that goes from
ct to k, right?
c, associated with the trail,
t, which I decided not to use.
OK, right.
So the basic point
here is that there
are a bunch of
different states where
I can traverse this trail.
But I have to have at
least c critters in my bag
if I'm allowed to
traverse this trail,
or else I will be sad, OK?
And so I kind of copy this
edge a bunch of different times
to represent all the possible
transitions I can make.
And similarly, let's say
that a does have a store.
Well, I still want
to add an edge.
But now I have the
luxury of clearing out
all the stuff in my bag before
collecting the critters, yeah?
So now I still want
an edge of length l.
But now I get to
connect more vertices
and reset my state
in the process.
So now I'm going to go
from va comma i to vb.
And where am I going to end up?
Well, how many critters
are going to be in my bag?
I have a bag of capacity k.
And I just traversed
this edge from a to b,
which contained c critters.
So I get a v k
minus c, like that.
And of course, I can do
that for all i from--
oh yeah.
I have to be careful--
well, no.
Actually just for all i is fine.
Yeah.
I think there might be--
there's either a mistake
in how I copied it down
or a mistake in the problem--
a mistake in the problem.
AUDIENCE: Do you still
need [INAUDIBLE]??
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah,
I think this is right.
Yeah, so I think there's--
we wrote for all i in some
interval, but we didn't have to.
OK.
Right, so those are our
different cases, right?
So essentially, in this case,
we clear out our queue here.
Well, not even a queue,
just our set of spheres.
We reset and go big here.
Notice that the second
vertex doesn't even
have an i in its index,
because it doesn't matter.
OK.
And then similarly-- so
that gets me from a to b.
I also have to do the symmetric
thing to go from b to a.
OK, so now I have a graph.
And first of all, we
should reason and make sure
that we can actually
construct this graph
in a reasonable amount of time.
So let's do that really fast.
Right.
So the number of
vertices in our graph--
well, I basically have k
plus 1 copies of my graph.
So it's equal to
k plus 1 times n.
And that's good.
So that's order kn time--
order kn space, I suppose.
And similarly, there's
k edges that are
associated with every trail.
And there's order n trails,
because I have a degree bound.
So overall, there's order
kn edges in my graph, OK?
Great.
So now my problem is not so bad.
I have a source, which is the
place where our walker starts.
I have t, which is
the destination, where
she wants to go.
So what do I need?
Well, I just need any path
that starts at v s, k.
In other words, she starts at
s and has a full bag with k
capacity, and ends up at--
to v t comma i for
any i, because it
doesn't matter how much
capacity she has in her bag
when she reaches
her destination.
So this is for all i.
Any path avoids sadness in the
way this problem is written.
So how could I do that?
Well, she wants
the shortest path.
So I can just do Dijkstra's
algorithm, from v s, k.
I'm going to do a bit
of cleanup afterward
to check all the different
i's and find this closest one.
And how much time
does that take?
Well, my graph takes kn
space, because it has
kn vertices and order kn edges.
So overall, this is going
to take order kn log kn
time, which is a good thing,
because that's exactly
what the problem asks for.
And of course, if the shortest
path is infinity, then
what do we know?
You can say it with me.
Sadness is unavoidable.
[LAUGHTER]
That's just a weird thing
to write on a blackboard.
OK, and so that's our
basic problem here.
So what was our strategy?
If we step back 10 feet,
essentially, we took our graph.
And rather than just making our
graph, we made k copies of it
with edges that kind
of point upstairs,
meaning that you
give away spheres
in the process of traversing
these different edges,
except when you hit the
stores, which brings you back
to level 0.
So that was our basic
graph structure.
And then we just need to do
shortest path on that thing.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Last time we did
graph duplication, we made--
it was layered graph.
And you kept making
these transitions.
And it was a DAG.
So can't we do this
in linear time?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Can't we
do this in linear time?
So in other words,
why is our graph not
a DAG in this particular case?
Let me think about
that for a second.
There's nothing about
this problem that says
that the graph has to be a DAG.
In particular, I guess
you could keep walking--
like, if you had a
path with a store that
were exactly the same as
the number of critters,
you could keep walking back
and forth along that path.
And so there's a
little cycle there,
which would be enough to not be
able to do it in linear time.
AUDIENCE: Well, the edges
that we constructed are not--
don't necessarily
correspond to the edges
in the original trails.
That's not in the problem.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Sure.
That's absolutely right.
So we constructed a directed
graph out of our original one.
But that directed graph also
can contain cycles, right?
So yeah, so I think the
example I'm giving you works.
So I have a graph
with two vertices.
Maybe there's other graph
stuff going on, but whatever.
I have two vertices here.
And I have some number
of critters here.
And I have a store on
either end of my edge,
just because I'm boring
and conservative.
And now, well, assuming
that c is less than k,
I can just keep going back
and forth along this edge
as many times as I want.
And this is for free, right?
Because every time I get
to the end of the edge,
I throw all my critters away.
So that's an example
of a cycle in my graph.
And because there's a cycle,
I'm not in the DAG case anymore.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's a cycle
in the constructed graph.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Sorry.
Yeah, it is a
cycle here and also
a cycle in the
constructed graph.
Yeah, sorry.
I guess that's true.
All right, any other questions
I can make a hash of here?
Excellent.
So am I out of time?
Ah, shucks.
No.
OK.
In that case, we'll do
the last problem here.
Actually, the last
problem, I think,
is the most interesting one.
So as usual, I've blessed
myself with not enough time.
OK, which of these
boards is the tidiest?
I think the answer is none of--
yeah, none of the above.
So let's use the backs here.
OK, right.
So our last problem is
a shipping problem, not
a trans-shipment
problem, which happens
to be my area of
research, but rather,
just a good old shipping thing.
So here, strangely, I did not
give myself my complete notes.
So this will be fun.
Right.
So I'm trying to ship servers
from San Francisco to Cambridge
by truck.
And I have all these bunch
of third-parity companies
that all have pairs of cities
that they can ship between,
and only so much.
These companies
are kind of divas.
They have a weight limit.
They only have cities.
They're directed edges.
Like, they don't drive their
trucks back, apparently,
or maybe they pick up
somebody else's stuff,
and they're just
picking your stuff up
in the boring
direction, or whatever.
So I have a bunch of--
I have n trucking routes.
And each route, r sub i, is
a tuple with si, ti, wi, ci.
And what are all these things?
So here, this is the source
of every shipping route,
every trucking route here.
This is the target, right?
So this is like where
the truck starts.
This is where the truck ends.
This is the max weight
that the truck can handle.
So the truck only has
so much space in it.
The tires are only so big.
And if I put something
of weight bigger than w,
then my truck is going to die.
So that's the most that
I can put on this truck.
And this is the cost.
OK.
And I have n routes
that look like this.
And I'm trying to ship servers.
And of course, some of my
servers are too darn busy.
By the way, we make
an assumption here,
which is that our
trucking routes form
a sort of continuous network.
I can get from s to t and
ship, at the very least,
like a pencil eraser, like
some minimal amount of weight.
OK, and so the basic
endpoint of this problem
is going to be to figure out the
heaviest thing that I can ship.
And we give you a
problem on the path
toward that to help prove
a little bit about this.
This is a very
typical kind of setup.
So again, I've got a
bunch of trucking routes,
each one of which
has a max weight.
And I'm going to
want to know, first
of all, what's the maximum
amount of weight I can ship?
And then what is the minimum
cost I can ship that weight?
So in problem A, which is
marked as useful digression,
we're first going to prove
kind of a handy inequality.
I decided to go off book with my
proof ever so slightly of this.
So get excited for this to be
slightly wrong in a subtle way,
which is what I specialize in.
But in particular, we're going
to make a definition here.
So let's say that pi
is a weighted path.
Then the bottleneck
of pi is going
to be the minimum edge
weight of any edge in pi.
And to make sure that we
see how this is connected
to the problem, if I'm
trying to ship a server,
and I have to put it on truck
1, and truck 2, and truck
3, and truck 4, and truck
5, obviously, of those five
trucks, the one whose
capacity for weight
is the smallest is
the only one that
matters in terms of the
heaviest thing that I can ship.
OK.
So, right.
Now, given a directed
graph and two vertices,
s and t, going to define a
quantity called b of s comma t.
And we're going to
say that this is
the max over any path, pi, from
s to t of the bottleneck of pi.
OK, so to sanity check this
quantity here, essentially,
what it's saying is,
at the end of the day,
I have this big network
of trucking routes.
I just want to go from
one city to another.
And I don't care which series
of trucks I want to use.
I just want to maximize the
weight that I can ship, right?
And so this is saying
I'm going to look
at all the different
paths that I could take.
Each path is sort
of band limited
by the one truck
that has the lightest
weight that it can carry.
And I'm going to find the path
that has the best bottleneck
as measured by this quantity.
I'm using the word
"best" because I
tend to make sign mistakes.
And that's a vague term.
OK.
And then, right.
So I'm writing too big.
Hopefully I won't
run out of space.
We're going to make one
additional definition, which
is I of t is the
incoming neighbors of t.
And then the problem
is asking you
to prove a particular
inequality here,
claim, which is
that b of s, t is
bigger than or equal to the
min of two values, b of s,
v, or w of v, t,
for all v in I of t.
So let's see what
this is saying.
So remember that this
is like the capacity
that I can ship from s
to t using any route,
and that that upper bound's the
minimum of two things, right?
Either the capacity of
shipping to one of my neighbors
with an incoming
edge or the weight
of basically shipping
from that neighbor to me.
Notice, this is kind of similar
to a triangle inequality, which
is why we're going
to kind of know
how to solve part B of
this problem pretty easily.
OK.
And moreover, with equality
for some v star in i of t, OK?
Guess what that v
star is going to be.
It's going to be
the vertex that's
sort of the previous one
on the path of trucks
that I actually take
to ship stuff, right?
OK.
So how could we prove this?
So the intuition here is
that the path that's actually
giving you this bottleneck,
this b s comma t,
has to include one
of my incoming edges.
And I'm just trying
to find it, right?
That's roughly what's going
on in this inequality.
And by the way,
whenever a problem
asks you to prove an
inequality, just step back.
Like, I feel like I
spend like 85% of my day
with research students
sort of saying, like, OK,
but like, what is this
really telling me about life?
And this is a good example.
OK, so to that end, I'm going
to make a definition, which
I found to be convenient when I
was solving this problem, which
is the following.
I'm going to say
that pi s comma t is
going to be the actual path
that gives me the bottleneck.
So this is kind of like
the arg max over all pi--
I'm going to use
really bad notation--
pis that connect s through t.
That's how we're going to
think of the bottleneck.
So in other words,
this is the path
that actually realizes
this quantity, b, right?
So in other words, b of s,
t is equal to bottleneck--
pi only has two lines--
s, t.
This is convenient for
me, because the reasoning
about that path
makes some sense.
OK.
So now, we're going to
prove the inequality first.
And then we may or may not
prove the equality case,
depending on how I feel.
OK, so right.
So let's section this off
and try and use my board
a little more
conservatively here.
OK, so right.
So now let's take a vertex,
v, from the incoming edges
here of t, because that's
what we need to prove this.
And we're going to prove the
inequality directly here.
In particular, we can
define a path that
goes from s to t as follows.
I could take the pi s,
v, and then concatenate
onto the end of this guy, t,
because we know that there's
a directed edge from v to t, by
definition of what this i is,
OK?
Right.
And so this is
kind of convenient,
because this is
like the bottleneck
path for one of my neighbors.
And now I'm just kind of
sticking an edge on there.
And we know that, of course,
this is a candidate path
to get from s to t.
But it may not be
the one that actually
achieves the bottleneck.
OK?
Right, so yeah.
And let's-- oops, let's
define that to be pi twiddle,
just for fun.
I like to give things names.
OK.
So what do we know?
We know that b of s comma t--
well, this, by definition,
is the max bottleneck
of any incoming path
going from s to t.
This is a path
from s to t, yeah?
So because this
is the max, it is
bigger than or equal to
bottleneck of pi twiddle,
right?
That's the nice
thing about maxes,
is they tend to be
bigger than other stuff.
OK.
Well, what is the
bottleneck of pi twiddle?
Well, remember our definition
of bottleneck here, right?
It's the min edge weight
over my entire path.
Well, I have two options.
Either that edge weight
is the edge from v to t,
or it's the edge weight
that's associated
to the rest of this stuff, yeah?
So either this is the min of the
bottleneck of the first segment
of our path, pi s, v--
by the way, that may be empty.
And that's OK.
That's just like
a one-edge path.
We can dispense with
that case pretty easily.
Or the weight of v, t.
Cool?
Well, by definition,
bottleneck of pi
s, v is exactly this
quantity, because that's
what I chose it to
be over here, yeah?
So this is exactly
min of b s comma v--
that was supposed to be
a v, but I wrote a t--
or w of v comma t.
And that is exactly what
we wanted to prove, yeah?
So that takes care of
our inequality case.
Do I want to do
the equality case?
I don't think I do, yeah.
So it's not too hard to
check the equality case.
Essentially, you can make a
pretty easy contradiction,
right?
Because if it's strictly larger,
then what does that mean?
That means that every single
incoming edge, none of them
can be the edge where your
bottleneck path comes in.
And obviously, there's
something wrong with that.
OK, so I'll refer you guys
to the notes for that one.
And finally, the problem
says, assuming that--
so now we have kind of a
funny constant in here, just
to make your life a
little bit annoying.
We have at most 3 square root
n cities that we care about.
Again, why 3?
Why not?
I think.
And what we want is the weight
of the single largest server
and the minimum cost
to ship that thing.
So we want, one, the
largest weight we can ship.
We'll call that w star to ship.
And two is the smallest cost to
ship that weight, w star, OK?
So let's do two first,
because it's easy.
So let's say that I was
able to compute w star.
So now what can I do?
Well, I can construct a graph
where I only keep around
the trucks that can ship at
least this amount of weight,
because the other ships are--
I really want them to be
boats in this problem.
But the other trucks
are useless, right?
If they can't cover w
star, then they're not
pulling their weight, yeah?
So to do part two
here, what can I do?
I can make a new graph, G sub
c, with a vertex for every city
and--
right-- and an edge--
a directed edge, sorry,
per shipping route with--
this is going to
be an unfortunate
clash in terminology.
I'm going to say
edge weight to refer
to the edge weight in my graph.
And that's going to be equal
to the cost of the edge.
And only keep around--
but only for routes that can
carry at least w star amount
of weight.
And now what do we do?
Well, it's just
shortest path, right?
At this point,
shortest path, which
is really the minimum
cost in this case,
because that's what we're
associating to the edges,
is going to give me the cost of
shipping w star in my network.
I think that's pretty obvious
from this construction.
So that's Dijkstra,
D-I-J-K-S-T-R-A.
And now the only question is,
how much time does it take?
So let's say that I do the
braindead version of Dijkstra,
where I just use a direct access
array to do my priority queue.
So if you recall, that'll take
big O of mod v cubed here--
squared?
Squared.
Yep, you're right.
Sorry.
I was thinking
Johnson's algorithm.
OK.
Well, in this
case, how big is v?
Well, it's square
root of n, 3 times
square root of n, at most.
So of course, v squared
is really big O of n.
And that part is solved, yeah?
So really, our only remaining
problem here is to do part one.
And I don't have
nearly enough time.
In fact, I'm
completely out of time.
So maybe we'll just talk
through it really briefly.
Sorry about that.
Essentially, the
basic observation
here is that the
inequality that we
proved in part A
of our problem is
kind of like the triangle
inequality of the bottleneck
world, in some sense.
Essentially, what it's giving
you is some update formula that
looks kind of like
the update formula
that we would
apply in Dijkstra's
algorithm for shortest
path, the basic assumption
here being that,
well, my shortest path
has to come from
somewhere, right?
So if I look at
all my neighbors,
and then I kind of add
in my closest edge,
or rather, the sum
of the path length
to the previous vertex
plus the edge to me,
that gives the
shortest path to me.
Here, instead of that, we're
saying the biggest bottleneck
path.
So what do I do?
I look at all of my
incoming neighbors.
I find the one with the
biggest bottleneck, which
is band limited by
their bottleneck,
plus the bottleneck
of the incoming edge.
And then I update myself.
So the only thing remaining
here is to basically do
exactly Dijkstra's algorithm.
But rather than updating
by summing edge lengths,
we update by using this formula.
And essentially, everything
else remains the same.
So conveniently,
I've run out of time.
So I won't even have to
jumble this one on the board.
I'll let you guys
do that one at home.
But I actually think the
explanation in the written
material is pretty
self-evident for this problem.
So that's probably just as well.